jetzt haben wir mal hände an die
hosennaht und haltung annehmen die queen
meine damen und herren queen elizabeth
die zweite feiert ihr 70 das
thronjubiläum
sie hat praktisch die ganze woche
hindurch gefeiert es ist der wahnsinn
die frau die frau hier ist absolut
unkaputtbar hat bereits 14
premierminister überstanden angefangen
mit winston churchill damals in der
jungsteinzeit also jetzt mal nichts
gegen unseren weiskopf ruder im schloss
bellevue aber da kann man schon neidisch
werden auf die britische königin oder
ach die ist gar keine briten sagt wer
gloria von thurn und taxis ja dann muss
es ja stimmen natürlich feiern wir unser
deutsches königshaus das englische
königshaus ist ja doppelt deutsch die
englische königin hat also mehr
deutsches blut als englisches blut die
holländer sind ja auch deutsche
deutsches deutschland den deutschen
deutschlands deutsche es ist ja auch
unsere königin sie ist ja schließlich
deutsche
natürlich natürlich die queen ist
deutsche keiner guckt fährt er auf der
rechten straßenseite die trägt sandalen
mit socken meine damen und herren
natürlich so queens deutsche wusste
selber noch nicht die die frage ist wie
lange die frau das alles noch schafft
mit ihren 96 jahren großbritannien
diskutiert schon über eine ablösung zu
lebzeiten andererseits ist prinz charles
dafür wirklich schon reichen das ist ja
der 73-jährige biobauer aus wales so
oder so die windsors müssen ein ziemlich
gespaltenes land zusammenhalten
allerdings machen sie das nicht für umme
allein im letzten jahr erhielt die royal
family über 100 millionen euro
steuergeld ziemlicher luxus für ein land
das gleichzeitig unter den folgen von
breck cit corona und inflation leidet
ist ja so
vor allem die armut im norden von
england nimmt wirklich dramatische
ausmaße an und ob senkt die regierung
von boris johnson auch noch die
sozialleistung armut ist schlimm genug
aber armut und boris johnson das wünscht
man keinem im wahlkampf gefragt was eher
einer 77 jährigen sagen könne die den
ganzen tag mit dem bus fahre um warm zu
bleiben weil sie sich das heizen nicht
mehr leisten könne antwortete johnson
ich möchte erwähnen dass ich das
kostenlose 24 stunden senioren bus
ticket eingeführt habe
also erstens wie zynisch kann man sein
und zweitens das war sie eines
mindestens halb gelogen von ihm wie
immer ist er sein hobby quasi lügen auch
die wahrheit über die freitagspartie es
in seinem amtssitz während der
strengsten lockt uns in london aber nur
scheibchenweise zugegeben version 1 ich
war gar nicht dabei dann tauchen solche
fotos hier auf
und was sagt ja woher soll ich wissen
dass das eine party ist nur weil da alle
besoffen war
wohlgemerkt während normale briten sich
bei beerdigungen nicht mal von ihren
liebsten verabschieden durfte ein
sonderbericht zu party geld hat der
regierung johnson jedenfalls gerade ein
verheerendes zeugnis ausgestellt in der
partie gate affäre hat ein interner
untersuchungsbericht dem britischen
premier johnson ver führungsversagen und
mangelndes urteilsvermögen bescheinigt
es hat es hat ver führungsversagen ist
einer der wenigen vorwürfe die mann
prinz andrew nicht machen kann aber dass
das wirklich nur am rande um von kathi
geld abzulenken schwadroniert johnson
jetzt nur noch über die wiedereinführung
der alten britischen maße wie harz oder
uns mit 1000 jahren am arsch vorbei
freunde hier echtes zitat aus dem
offiziellen untersuchungsbericht drinnen
also in downing street
erwischten putzkräfte morgens
gelegentlich erbrochenes und rotwein
spritzer von regierungs wenden die
industrie hat längst reagiert
kennen sie das jeden freitag vollgas
party der downing street und sie müssen
danach die folgekosten wende sauber
kratzen kein problem für meister
bordeaux wand reiniger mit der antike
zur formel gegen hartnäckige flecken und
rücktritte
[Musik]
jetzt mit drei unzen gratis
[Applaus]
boris johnson hat im parlament gesagt er
übernimmt die volle verantwortung tritt
aber natürlich nicht zurück weil dann
wäre ja nicht mehr premierminister wir
schalten wir live zu unserer heutigen
london korrespondent hin zu dieser frage
gesagt hat man denn in downing street an
inzwischen er hat die richtigen schlüsse
gezogen aus party gate natürlich oliver
auf kurs erstens kommen die partygäste
freitags jetzt nur noch durch den
seiteneingang und zweitens wurde gerade
ein neuer untersuchungsausschuss
eingesetzt der diesmal aber wirklich
schonungslos aufklärt was hier bei
diesen lockdown orgien vorgefallen ist
und da kommen auch gleich die ermittler
blieben hängen beziehungsweise chaz
in wirklichkeit sind wir deutschen doch
nur neidisch
natürlich ist boris johnson peinlich
aber eben auch extrem unterhaltsam hier
im januar bei twitter umgegangen
nicht sexy
man muss dazu sagen die schwammige
blondine mit der bierdose verfügt leider
über atomwaffen
ernsthaft können sie sich olaf scholz so
vorstellt gottes willen nicht mal beim
ententanz
johnsons taktik ist genial klar macht er
sich regelmäßig zum vollhorst lenkt
damit aber auch ab von den wirklichen
skandalen er seine regierung hat im
april gesetze erlassen die er zu einer
autokratie passen die sogenannten fakt
eins zum beispiel erlaubt der polizei
demonstration aufzulösen wenn sie zu
laut sind selbst wenn nur eine einzige
person demonstriert das innenministerium
kann menschen ihre britische
staatsbürgerschaft aberkennen ohne sie
davor den kenntnis zu setzen das
verstößt das nicht gegen völkerrecht un
flüchtlingskonvention
er war nicht schlecht welche ich kann
ihnen ja mal zeigen was boris johnson
gerade mit dem asylrecht macht
zur erklärung der kleine junge steht
hier symbolisch britischer asylrecht
wir sagen da bleibt nicht mehr viel von
übrig ab dem 14 juni fliegt
großbritannien asylbewerber pauschal
nach honda aus und dann können die da in
ruhe abwarten was aus ihrem asylantrag
wird oder halt für immer in afrika
bleiben jetzt auch flüchtlinge die gar
nicht aus afrika kommen ja klar wanda
kriegt für die aufbewahrung dieser
menschen 120 millionen pfund absolut
eklig aber jetzt muss ich los machen
heute ist da drin 90er jahre rave mit
stargast guter
start und immer an der drechselbank der
verteidigungsminister
ich wollte euch nur um ein kleines auto
bieten einfach anklicken
macht's gut
los
los du scheiße fährt haye